[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 17 juin bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres
il revient sur sa sortie dans l'espace
depuis l' iss l'astronaute thomas
pesquet était en direct cet après midi
pour échanger avec les étudiants de
l'université paris saclay une
retransmission suivie par 40 lycéens de
montigny le bretonneux depuis
l'amphithéâtre de l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
j moins 3 avant le premier tour des
départementales et régionales c'est ce
dimanche 20 juin les électeurs vont donc
se rendre aux urnes pour un double
scrutin
quels sont les enjeux quelles
compétences pour les deux collectivités
éléments de réponse anne charlène bezina
duclair maître de conférences en droit
public à sciences po paris sera
également notre invité et puis à partir
de demain et pendant trois jours ce sont
les journées européennes de
l'archéologie à cette occasion le musée
national d'archéologie installé à saint
germain en laye propose un programme
varié et visites activités notamment
village des savoir faire et des métiers
le détail à suivre et puis nous irons
également du côté d'aubergenville dans
ce journal ou un data center a été
inauguré ce jeudi
[Musique]
direction les étoiles pour le début de
ce journal 40 élèves du lycée saint
françois d'assise de montigny le
bretonneux ont suivi sur écran géant
un échange en direct avec l'astronaute
français thomas pesquet ils ont assisté
à cette retransmission depuis
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines le reportage de
mickaël millero cette voie que vous
entendez celle de thomas pesquet
l'astronaute français était en direct ce
jeudi 17 juin avec l'université paris
saclay la séance de questions réponses a
été suivi en temps réel par quarante
élèves du lycée saint françois d'assise
de montigny le bretonneux depuis
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et ça c'est émouvant
quand même parce qu'en fait on fait
qu'il en direct tout ça après
et puis il n'y avait pas énormément de
personnes en plus donc c'était cette
dépêche
c'était vachement bon c'est intéressant
par rapport à la manière dont ils nous
ont conseillés pour un autre exemple
nous a dit de toujours saisir les
occasions
la connexion à dure au total dix minutes
pas une de plus le cône finalement et
dans lequel avec lequel on peut
communiquer une certaine une certaine
taille
c'est compliqué surtout quand il ya
beaucoup de monde nous nous on fait ça
régulièrement parce que on a notre
propre talent satellite et notre propre
antenne mais c'est à chaque fois le
challenge malgré tout de recevoir de
faire la communication avec un satellite
avant cette retransmission des
animations avec des interviews un jeux
ont été organisés objectif mieux
comprendre la vie de thomas pesquet à
bord et pourquoi pas susciter des
vocations
c'est un secteur qui fait rêver mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer que
voilà il ya une multiples métiers de
compétences et participer au
développement du spatial aux sciences du
climat et de l'atmosphère est quelque
chose qui est complètement dans l'air du
temps
la journée s'est terminée par une visite
de l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de quoi avoir
des étoiles plein les yeux en rentrant à
la maison
l'entreprise these data center a
inauguré ce jeudi son site à
aubergenville une infrastructure
sécurisée qui accueillera les données
numériques de ses clients
le lieu se veut aussi respectueux de
l'environnement les détails dans ce
sujet de nicolas landry le nouveau data
center situé à aubergenville est sorti
de terre
un projet mené par l'entreprise these
datacenter un investissement de 10
millions d'euros pour ce site de 6400
mètres carrés de surface au sol
il pourra accueillir jusqu'à 400 b ces
grandes armoires composée de serveurs
informatiques
on saura quasiment avec 8 cage
et avec dans cette salle 250p
informatique dans 250 me informatique et
peut imaginer qu'il y ait deux mille
3000 serveurs informatiques
deux salles de ce type ont été
construites sur ce site une
infrastructure alimenté par un groupe
électrogène pour refroidir ces deux
espaces un système a été installé tout
l'air froid et souffler dans le faux
plancher essor à des endroits où il ya
des dalles perforé sont des éléments qui
sont noirs là bas qui permettent à l'air
de sortir les sortes sur les avants des
serveurs informatiques tesi datacenter
une entreprise 100% française
spécialisée dans le service
d'hébergement de serveurs numériques
avec une stratégie par rapport à
l'implantation à aubergenville on peut
accueillir des petits clients en
colocation qui vont prendre simplement
une baie ou 2b et accueillir des clients
moyens dans des cages privatives et
ensuite des grands clients qui peuvent
être des éditeurs de logiciels les gens
du cac 40 ou du top 100 français et qui
vont prendre un quart de sa lune de miel
voir un bâtiment complet par notre
actionnariat qui est 100% français on
vise les organismes publics
un deuxième bâtiment pourrait être
opérationnel dès 2023 à terme six data
center seront construits ici
sur les trente mille mètres carrés de
terrain
mais ce week-end plus précisément ce
dimanche nous voterons pour les
élections régionales et départementales
alors quels sont les principaux enjeux
de ces deux scrutins à venir
les 20 et 27 juin pour y répondre juste
in brazil est avec nous bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 qu'en est il déjà
pour les régionales justin alors 11-10
se présente déjà en ile-de-france la
favorite du scrutin
eh bien c'est la présidente sortante
valérie pécresse en 2015 elle avait
repris à la région à la gauche en
ile-de-france la liste est républicain
portait donc par valérie pécresse avait
obtenu 43 % du suffrage face au parti
socialiste 42% et le rassemblement
national front national à l'époque
arrivé en troisième position avec 14%
des voix
elle fait face cette année à une gauche
divisée clémentine autain pour la france
insoumise julien bayou pour l' europe
ecologie les verts et puis audrey pulvar
pour soutenue par le parti socialiste
une dispersion qui va forcément peser
dans la balance ce dimanche et se
ressentir donc dans les résultats
même si les listes de gauche s'unissent
pour le second tour valérie pécresse en
tête des intentions de vote pourrait
l'emporter et donc enchaîner un second
mandat voilà pour les régionales quels
sont les enjeux côté département dans
les yvelines la question qui se pose est
de savoir si la droite va faire un
nouveau chelem cette année comme c'était
le cas en 2015 lors des dernières
élections départementales la liste
ensemble pour les yvelines de droite et
du centre représentait donc par pierre
bédier président du département avait
fait un carton plein reportant les 21
cantons
et puis aussi particularité du parti
présidentiel qui présente seulement cinq
binômes dans le padd département cette
année et le rassemblement national
présente vingt binôme et un soutien et
quels sont les cantons à surveiller ce
week-end alors le canton de
mantes-la-jolie fait partie et des
cantons à suivre puisque c'est celui de
pierre bédier président sortant avec
donc sept binômes en lice autres cantons
également à surveiller celui de
bonnières sur seine avec laurent morin
pour représenter le rn et patrick
stefanini pour la droite un canton qui
verra s'opposer à des hommes politiques
expérimentés et puis le canton de
trappes va-t-il rebasculer à la gauche
cette année c'est le maire de trappes
très médiatisée ces derniers mois se
présente face au maire de la commune
voisine là
derrière nicolas d'un village et puis
autre enjeu justine et non des moindres
la participation exactement donc lors de
la dernière à des dernières élections en
2015 le taux de participation aux
régionales au premier tour était de 45%
54% pour le deuxième tour du côté des
départementales 45% au premier tour
également un peu moins au second tour
avec 42 % de participation alors grégory
on sait que ce ne sont pas les élections
qui attire le plus de monde d'autant
plus que les deux scrutins cette année
se déroulent en même temps ce qui court
circuite un peu les informations et
surtout la clarté à des messages et sans
oublier qu'on est évidemment en pleine
crise sanitaire donc ces facteurs font
qu on peut s'attendre à un faible taux
de participation cette année pour les
élections merci justin pour toutes ces
précisions et ont continué à parler de
ces deux scrutins avec mon invité en
visioconférence anne charlène bezina
duclair bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes maître
de conférences en droit public à
l'université de rouen à sciences po
paris a également et vous intervenez
également régulièrement dans l'émission
paf sur tv 78 parlant déjà de cette
participation qui est annoncé on va dire
avec des chiffres assez bas pour ce
week-end on l'a vu aussi un lors des
dernières élections en 2015 moins d'un
électeur sur deux s'était déplacée aux
urnes pour les élections départementales
un peu plus d'un sur deux pour les
élections régionales est en tout cas
c'est pour le second tour puisque au
premier tour y avait aussi moins d'un
électeur sur deux qui s'étaient déplacés
comment expliquer ce désintérêt des
électeurs pour ces deux scrutins
je dirais qu'il ya peut-être deux
facteurs le premier c'est la complexité
de notre organisation territoriale qui
est vraiment symptomatique d'un esprit
de clocher français qui nous est souvent
critiquée d'ailleurs à l'international
parce que précisément nous avons une
myriade de communes des départements des
régions dont le citoyen ne sait pas
nécessairement quelles sont les
compétences d'autant qu'elles sont elles
sont souvent très proches
le second facteur c'est peut-être
quelque chose d'un peu plus grave encore
est un désintérêt progressif de la vie
politique et de la vie politique locale
notamment parce qu'on ne se rend pas
forcément compte des enjeux alors
pourtant que dans des périodes comme
cette crise sanitaire on s'est rendu
compte à quel point c'était les
collectivités territoriales qui étaient
les premières au fond
si je peux utiliser cette expression
puisque précisément la proximité c'est
peut-être le moment où on a le plus
besoin de la politique donc c'est une
gérer que c'est une dérive de complexité
et peut-être désintéressement
vous parlez de ce désintérêt pour la vie
politique des français en général est ce
que du coup ce manque de participation
que l'on a vu pour les dernières
régionales et dernière départemental en
2015 est ce que ça a toujours existé en
somme c'est quelque chose de nouveau à
l'image vous lisiez de ce désintérêt
progressif des français pour pour leurs
politiques pour leur vie politique
alors il faut dire une chose c'est que
déjà les départementales sont quand même
les mal aimés de la république en
général et les départements si on devait
généralisée puisque ce sont les échelons
mais moins connu et donc les élections
qui généralement en porte ou moins de
suffrages
c'est moins vrai pour les régionales qui
pendant longtemps séduisait quand même
assez émouvant l'électorat parce que
c'est vrai qu'on se rendait un petit peu
plus compte des enjeux il ya eu cette
réforme territoriale qui a fait passer
les régions de 22 à 12 qui a peut-être
complexifier aussi encore les choses qui
à mon avis encore accentué ce désintérêt
mais le scrutin local en général à part
le scrutin municipal a du mal à susciter
l'intérêt et le deuxième mouvement
concomitants c'est qu'en effet les
élections en général suicide de moins en
moins d'intérêt alors la crise sanitaire
n'est évidemment pas de la partie pour
nous aider puisque il ya cette absence
de proximité qui est quand même quelque
chose de très marquant pour les
élections locales c'est à dire qu'on a
besoin de ce serrage de main cette
présence sur les marchés qui est
vraiment un faux symptomatique de
l'élection locale à la française et son
ce contact j'ai envie de dire ça devient
encore plus difficile pour les élections
locales pour des élections plus grande
ampleur mais doit-on craindre du coup
une abstention massive ce dimanche pour
le premier tour vous parliez de la crise
sanitaire il ya aussi le fait que ces
deux scrutins se déroulent en même temps
ça risque de semer le trouble aussi dans
la tête des électeurs
alors comme vous le dites on doit le
craindre et on doit inciter finalement
tous ceux qui nous écoutent ce soir en
en disant voilà vous êtes attaché à tv
78 donc forcément à un attachement
régionales et il faut il faut le montrer
évidemment puisque
c'est important n'oublions pas aussi que
élire nos représentants départementaux
régionaux municipaux sert à élire nos
sénateurs qui sont la deuxième assemblée
de la république c'est à dire ceux qui
vont voter no future loi demain donc il
ya évidemment de l'ours en jeu est ce
que le fait de mixer les scrutins est
encore un facteur de confusion je le
crois malheureusement puisque c'est vrai
que déjà les alliances ne sont pas les
mêmes les compétences ne sont pas les
mêmes les enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes
donc ça devient très complexe crise
sanitaire oblige on nous a donc obligé à
mixer un peu des scrutins comme ça pour
des raisons praticité qui qui évidemment
doit vous faire craindre que avant même
ce niveau d'abstention que le citoyen ne
se sentent plus représentés et ne
connaissent plus même le sens de cette
représentation alors c'est pourquoi
aussi il faut communiquer autour de tout
cela et peut-être que là la vraie
carence et que notre pays à l'inversé
d'autres comme les états unis
l'allemagne n'a pas réussi pendant cette
crise sanitaire à maintenir l'engouement
pour ces élections à maintenir une
connexion pourquoi pas par me net
parlera par d'autres moyens
alors pourtant que il faudrait rappeler
que surtout dans ces moments ces deux
politiques dont nous avons besoin et
surtout politique locale poker merci
anne charlène bezina duclair pour cette
analyse merci à vous et je rappelle que
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de rouen sciences po paris
et je précise également que vous
intervenez régulièrement dans l'émission
paf sur tv 78 alors les départements et
les régions sont avec les communes ce
qu'on appelle des collectivités
territoriales ils sont tous deux régies
par un conseil et un président qui
seront donc élus les 20 et 27 juin
prochains mais quelles sont les
compétences de ces deux entités ont la
vue ça peut semer le trouble parfois
dans la tête des électeurs alors pour
répondre à cette question
bixente maria santisteva n'a rejoint un
plateau bon soir en soir de la rédaction
de tv 78 ton commence par le département
à quoi sert-il concrètement la
prérogative principal du département va
concerner la solidarité et la cohésion
territoriale
l'action sociale représente plus de la
moitié de son budget on y retrouve
notamment l'aide sociale à l'enfance la
protection maternelle et infantile
l'adoption le soutien aux familles en
difficulté financière mais le social ce
n'est pas que la petite enfance
le département est en charge des aides
aux personnes
âgées et handicapées notamment avec la
gestion des maisons de retraite ou
encore les prestations de compensation
du handicap
autre rôle social et pas des mots et
mais pas des moindres la gestion du rsa
revenu de solidarité active et
l'accompagnement vers le retour à
l'emploi
et ce n'est pas tout le département et
en charge aussi de l'éducation et de
l'aménagement du territoire
oui dans les yvelines cela se traduit
par l'entretien des 145 collèges publics
et des 1500 45 km de routes
départementales mais également le
développement de projets comme
l'équipement rural l'aménagement foncier
ou la gestion de l'eau en ce qui
concerne le sport la culture est ce que
ça fait aussi partie des prérogatives du
département en partie oui le département
partage certaines prérogatives avec les
communes les collectivités à statut
particulier comme l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines par exemple ou
encore la région donc culture sport mais
aussi tourism promotion des langues
régionales éducation populaire et lutte
contre la fracture numérique sont
discutées entre les différents échelons
territoriaux du département on en vient
donc à la région quelles sont les
compétences de la région
j'aime bien depuis la loi notre du 7
août ce 2015 la région n'a plus le droit
d'intervenir au nom de l'intérêt public
local dans tous les domaines la loi de
notre fait de la région la responsable
du développement de l'économie avec en
charge également l'aménagement durable
du territoire et comment cela se traduit
sur le terrain concrètement en
ile-de-france par un travail notamment
sur les transports avec ile-de-france
mobilité la gestion des 475 décès public
l'accès à la formation professionnelle
des jeunes et des adultes
la gestion des parcs naturels régionaux
et le plan national pour la qualité de
l'air et côté économie la région doit
donner le chemin régional de
développement économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation
à noter aussi que la région un dernier
rollin dans l'aide aux entreprises aux
collectivités et aux associations et aux
milieux éducatifs pour solliciter l'aide
des financements auprès de l'union
européenne merci bixente mes ressentis
steban pour toutes ces précisions
premier tour donc à venir des élections
départementales et régionales ce
dimanche et si vous ne pouvez pas aller
voter physiquement sur place vous pouvez
avoir recours aussi à une procuration
trois solutions s'offrent à vous vous
télécharger un formulaire papier sur le
portail service public.fr documents à
remplir et 1
prix mais avant de vous rendre dans un
commissariat si vous ne disposez d'aucun
matériel informatique rendez vous
directement au commissariat les forces
de l'ordre vous fournirons un imprimé à
remplir sur place enfin dernière
solution et c'est une nouveauté depuis
le 6 avril
et vous pouvez faire votre demande de
procuration également en ligne sur le
site ma procuration point gouv.fr une
fois la requête valider un numéro de
dossier et vous sera transmis par mail
il faut ensuite se rendre dans le
commissariat avec cette référence et
avec une pièce d'identité pour valider
la demande j'ajoute enfin que la
personne qui votera à votre place doit
être inscrite dans la même commune mais
pas forcément dans le même bureau de
vote que vous exceptionnellement 1
durant cette crise sanitaire
un mandataire peut avoir deux
procurations dans le reste de
l'actualité l'action salvatrice de deux
chiens policiers à moka et il m'a tard
ont permis de porter secours à une
adolescente qui voulait mettre fin à ses
jours le flair de ces deux animaux l'a
affecté à la brigade cynophile les
yvelines l'autre à la compagnie
cynophile de paris a permis de retrouver
la trace et de cette adolescente
disparue à versailles lundi dernier la
jeune femme de 16 ans a été retrouvé aux
alentours de 19 heures dans le quartier
de satory assise au pied d'un arbre
elle avait avalé des médicaments et
s'était entaillé les veines
l'adolescente a été ensuite conduit
conduite à l'hôpital tout autre chose
les 18 et 19 et 20 juin également ce
sont les journées européennes de
l'archéologie pour la quatrième année
consécutive est le musée d'archéologie
nationale située à saint germain en laye
participé parmi le programme la
découverte de pièces habituellement
fermés au public avant goût avec mélanie
poké d'interdiction public il n'en sera
pas question ce week-end est derrière
cette porte se trouvent un trésor
plus de cinquante trois mille ouvrages
spécialisés accessible aux personnels et
chercheurs le service des ressources
documentaires recèle à la fois des
pièces d'archivés des documents des
cartes des mémoires de fouilles des
ouvrages commentée par leurs auteurs
mais aussi des ouvrages très anciens
nous avons des ouvrages du 16ème 17ème
siècle ce samedi elle va dévoiler un peu
de son histoire de l'émergence de
l'archéologie
le travail d'érudits locaux comme paul
guégan saint germanois l'attaquent
heures après de naviguer dans tout le
département donc à l'époque l'acte enfin
l'ancien département de seine et oise
pour recenser les vestiges matériel
archéologique et qu'il dessine il avait
un talent pour en faire une énorme
monographique n'a jamais été publié
autres lieux inédits la salle 16 du
musée fermé au public depuis 2018 pour
travaux elle révélera les enjeux du
chantier des collections comme celle de
la mosaïque de saint romain en gal
c'est aussi l'occasion d'expliquer les
métiers de la conservation les coulisses
du musée ce qu'on fait quand on est pour
ces amateurs du patrimoine quand on est
assistant de conservation le travail
qu'on mène à la fois sur les collections
sur les restaurations sur l'histoire des
lieux puisque on a beaucoup travaillé
ces derniers mois sur la muséographie
ces visites inédites s'inscrivent dans
le programme des journées européennes
d'archéologie le musée il participe pour
la 4e année c'est ici que ce que se
tient le village des savoir-faire
franciliens et donc qui permet
d'accueillir différents professionnels
de diverses institutions de
l'archéologie que ce soit à
l'archéologie de terrain l'archéologie
de laboratoire ou encore l'archéologie
en musée une édition à la saveur
particulière pour les équipes après une
réouverture le 19 mai dernier pour
découvrir les coulisses du musée une
inscription est obligatoire
deux concerts seront également proposées
à 14 heures et 16 heures par l'ensemble
calliopée dans la chapelle du château
vous pourrez d'ailleurs retrouver à ce
concert sur l'antenne de tv 78 une
diffusion prévue le 3 juillet prochain à
partir de 20h30 un mot de sport pour
refermer ce journal sur une future
pépite du rugby français le versaillais
léobard et a été titularisé dans
l'équipe de france des moins de 20 ans
une sélection face à l'angleterre pour
la première rencontre du tournoi des six
nations 2021 dans la catégorie
c'est ce samedi 19 juin 18h à cardiff au
pays de galles pour rappel les au bar et
joue au stade français en équipe espoir
depuis cette saison il a performé réussi
à jouer quelques matches en top 14 avec
l'équipe première
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]